hallo mein name ist lookout auch wenn
man das will ich an sieht mein
traumberuf war es schon immer architekt
zu werden
ja ich glaube das liegt mir wirklich
nicht allerdings fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich hey warum erzählt ja uns
das alles überhaupt ok vielleicht fragt
es euch doch nicht weil er schon den
titel gesehen habt wir schauen uns heute
gemeinsam einige der kuriosesten
architektur design fällt an also ich
würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
dieser garage die irgendwie bis hier zu
hoch geraten ist ja oder park ich dann
einfach meinen privatjet drin das hier
ist der nächste design fällt und er
fragt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich hey
warum hat er einen hund drauf gepackt
naja das soll so das ist er wirklich so
bei dem teppich mit dabei wer sagt denn
ja klar das sieht gut aus dem
produzieren wir so machen wir allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten design
fällt und zwar geht es dabei um diese
toilette
also ich meine die rechts ist ja auch
völlig normaler höhe aber die da hinten
ich weiß nicht die wäre perfekt wenn
einer kotzen muss ja ich weiß nicht wer
sowas durchwinkt und ich weiß auch nicht
wer eine bettwäsche in diesem rosen
design durchwinkt das sieht aus wie ein
mord schauplatz machen allerdings recht
weiter mit dem nächsten architektur feld
und zwar geht es hier wieder um einen
bart allerdings diesmal nicht um einen
piste sondern um ein waschbecken und ich
laufe jetzt schon erkennen was ihr rad
irgendwie falsch sein könnte der nächste
design feld spielt sich zur abwechslung
mal nicht in einem badezimmer ab sondern
auf einer kreuzung und zwar ja ich
glaube ihr seht auch hier schon was
falsch ist was ist das für unnötige
asphaltierter umweg als nächstes kommen
wir nicht wirklich zu einem architektur
oder mehr oder weniger die sein fell
sondern es ist ein allgemeiner fällt
würde ich sagen
und zwar ist es ein buch über plastik
und zwar wege wie man also in seinem
eigenen leben plastik aus dem eigenen
leben verdrängen kann das buch ist
allerdings in plastik verpackt also da
hat er auf jeden fall lagen mit dem kopf
getroffen
keine ahnung ob das sprichwort gerade
sinn gemacht hat oder ob es das
sprichwort überhaupt gibt
allerdings würde ich sagen machen wir
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten design
fällt und zwar geht es hierbei um eine
kleidung beziehungsweise um einen pulli
ihr seht schon hier oben and animal
cruelty klappt also wir sind gegen
tierversuche und das sind design vom
anti social club die haben allerdings
nicht die kapuze es ist nicht lustig es
sind hier versuche aber dieser fall dass
meine ich dass das wie kann man sowas
nicht denken und hat was jemand auch
nicht so richtig gedacht hat gerade
hinsichtlich der funktionsweise eines
produktes ist der designer dieser treppe
wieso machst du die das dass das wieso
machst du das nicht gerade alter wenn
ich besoffen bin ich werde schon 30 mal
runter gefallen
mit dem nächsten design fällt und zwar
hat hier jemand einen fisch mit einem
hühnchen gepaart und ich hoffe du
wurdest gefeuert weil das ist ganz ganz
verstörend die nächste sache habe ich
mit reingenommen das heutige compilation
video weil ich selber das ganze nicht so
richtig verstehe es handelt sich um
diesen schuh und ich verstehe nicht
warum da solche saugnäpfe irgendwie
darunter sind keine ahnung adidas ob das
irgendwie cool aussehen soll aber falls
es irgendeinen sinn haben sollte erklärt
mit dem bitte
das hier ist der nächste design bzw
architektur fell und zwar ist das eine
öffentliche toilette auf der eine fast
durchsichtige scheibe an die toilette
eingebaut wurde
also ja wenn ihr beim kacken beobachtet
werden wollt dann solltet ihr definitiv
dort auf toilette gehen zum nächsten
architektur feld musste ich glaube ich
gar nicht viel zu sagen und zwar zeige
ich euch einfach mal dieses wohnzimmer
ich lasse das einfach mal so
unkommentiert hier stehen allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
architektur fell und zwar ist es eine
sache die nicht drinnen ist sondern
draußen und ja auch hier muss ich glaube
ich nicht wirklich was zu sagen der
nächste architektur verändert mich
irgendwie so ein bisschen an den neuen
berliner flughafen
das ganze wird gebaut und man kommt
voran und irgendwann steht man hey
irgendwie fehlt das geld
und es geht nicht mehr richtig weiter
und entweder dann stoppt das projekt
sowie beim br flughafen oder man macht
einfach das beste draus
die leute diesem einkaufszentrum so da
sollte der rolltreppe hin aber nicht im
krieg hält mir deswegen machen wir es
doch eine gepflasterte treppe dahinter
nächsten design viel fragt man sich
eventuell auf den ersten blick erstmal
hey was ist daran falsch
ich zeige es euch einfach mal und zwar
ist das hier der design beziehungsweise
architektur fell und ihr seht es
allerdings auf dem zweiten blick wenn
ihr euch die leute mit den schirmen
anschaut das ist nämlich eine
bushaltestelle und irgendwie ja hat die
halt löcher die sollte cool aussehen
aber schlussendlich erfüllt sie nicht
den zweck und es regnet einfach durch
sie durch in der woche der nächste
architektur fälle handelt von einem fall
in einem krankenhaus und zwar hat der
boden gestellt haben falls es so einen
beruf gibt beziehungsweise der
innenarchitekt oder in ein richter keine
ahnung der hat auf jeden fall ganz schön
verpackt er hat nämlich den boden so
gestaltet und ich meine in einem
krankenhaus in blutrot haben den
geschwistern boden ist jetzt nicht so
dass aller klügste machen wir allerdings
direkt weiter wieder mit einem
badezimmer beziehungsweise genauer
gesagt mit einer toilette
beziehungsweise noch genauer gesagt mit
einer klobrille und zwar hat sich jemand
gedacht hey ich mache so ein cooles
wassertropfen design und dann sieht es
einfach so aus also ich würde mich da
nicht drauf setzen zunächst nach der
clou fällen muss ich glaube ich nicht
wieder viel zu sagen uns was ist das
hier das ist ein fenster mit einer
effektiven fensterfläche von vielleicht
drei quadratzentimetern ja wenn man halt
den ausblick genießen will machen wir
weiter mit einem design fehler bei dem
sich die person wirklich gedacht hat hey
das ist süß und ich meine ich finds auch
süß die funktionalität davon lässt
allerdings zu wünschen übrig und zwar
geht es um die sackgasse und ihr seht
schon wenn man es trinke dann stechen
einem die epa kann ja im wahrsten sinne
des wortes die augen aus sommer testet
ihr sowas nicht bevor ich das wenn die
produktion gibt das hier ist der nächste
design viel mehr oder weniger
beziehungsweise eventuell war es auch so
gewollt
wenn es allerdings so gewollt worden
wäre warum warum einfach ich meine ich
will mich doch nicht tausend mal beim
kacken selbst beobachten der nächste act
urfeld spielt sich an einer wand ab also
es ist ein poster beziehungsweise ein
plakat mit werbung für ein fitnessstudio
und für dieses fitnessstudio wurde
geworben mit einer dame die ja wasser
kapital ist klar beim nächsten diesem
fall handelt es sich um eine schrift
beziehungsweise um die schriftgröße
einzelner wörter und das hier ist das
poster
es ist eigentlich ein guter zweck wenn
man allerdings von ein bisschen weiter
weg liest liest man einfach nur donate
to help and children also es hört sich
so an als würden die eine petition
starten wollen dass keine kinder mehr
leben
die message ist glaube ich ein bisschen
nach hinten losgegangen
was allerdings auch nach hinten
losgegangen ist ist das design dieser
uhr ich meine irgendwo ist die idee cool
so von wegen hey wir machen keine
normale uhr sondern verteilen die
buchstaben in unterschiedlichen
entfernungen schlussendlich macht es die
eu allerdings unlesbar machen allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten diesen
fällen zwar handelt es sich dabei um
einen nissan um das design eines zahns
und zwar hat der zahn ein blatt zwischen
seinen wurzeln
jedes kind weiß dass ein zahn warum
macht ihr dann blatt hin beim nächsten
reckenfeld frage ich mich wieder hey was
haltet ihr für einen architekten
beziehungsweise vielleicht hat auch der
statiker
es dreht sich auf jeden fall um diese
säule und das geländer
ich mein ich muss sagt gar nichts zu
sagen die nächsten die sein fell fühle
ich so richtig
also ich spüre den wirklich und das
versteht ihr auch wenn ich euch jetzt
dieses foto hier zeige ich glaube unsere
kleinen szenen hätten nicht so viel spaß
mit diesem bett design machen allerdings
wenig weiter wieder mit einer toilette
und zwar hat jemand dort eine toilette
designte die er besser nicht die seit
hätte und zwar ich meine der
grundgedanke ist cool und stylisch
ich zeige es euch mal und das ist dort
so eine art rutsche zwischen waschbecken
und toilette das ding ist nur ihr seht
schon da und eine zahnbürste dritten
also wenn du da links oben deine zeit
fallen lässt rutscht sie halt
automatisch unter dem klodeckel durch in
die toilette wie blöd kann
was allerdings noch blöder ist es wenn
du eine nacht uhr entwickelst ohne dass
die zeiger auch leuchten wie blöd kann
man sein und wie blöd was du bitte bei
diesem design fällt das kostüm sieht
einfach aus wie ein arschloch
der nächste design viel dreht sich um
einen bankautomaten und da fragt man
sich jetzt wahrscheinlich hey was kann
man denn bei einem bankautomaten falsch
machen
na ja der ist ein wenig zu hoch
angebracht worden
ich denke
ihr baut das ding doch da rein müsste
man noch merken haye der ist irgendwie
ein bisschen zu hoch wie wir den grat
einbauen
aber na ja ich würde sagen wir machen
weiter mit dem letzten design fällt
jetzt schon jetzt für das heutige video
meine damen und herren und zwei es ist
ein design für den nicht extra ans ende
gepackt habe weil ich nicht so ganz
genau weiß was er dort eigentlich hin
schreiben wollte ich zeige euch einfach
mal dem feld ich lese dort noel ritzing
einem is possible
falls ihr wisst was der innenarchitekt
damit sagen wollte schreibt es mir auf
jeden fall bitte gerne in die kommentare
anders hätte mich dass ich wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde ganz viele von euch haben unter
mein letztes video vor einigen monaten
habe ich hab schon mal auf irgendwelche
architektur fans reagieren auf jeden
fall meinte ganz viele leute von euch
daher das war echt lustig macht dann
bitte noch einmal
deswegen habe ich noch mal 33 oder 32
stück rausgesucht
ich hoffe jedenfalls dass ich das heute
geblieben wäre es das getan hat ist auf
jeden fall einen daumen hoch unter dem
video da schreibt mir außerdem mitten in
die kommentare
was bei dem letzten fail die intention
war was dort wirklich hätte stehen
sollen
da bin ich echt gespannt abonniert zudem
gern main kanal
falls ich noch mal so ein video machen
soll und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]